all right what's the next category on we
have best out of context Club oh my God
all right
oh yeah I love this one
so God apparently said Chinese food
doesn't exist oh okay here's the thing I
don't think Chinese food exists right in
the sense
bro let me finish my point let me
[__] finish my point I can't believe
he'd do me like that
I love the air quotations
they know I'm liberals trying to tell me
this Chinese food exists I've never seen
it what I love about that is just the
pause before Joey just processing what I
said just Chan just like
no no hear me out hear me out guys let
me cook let me cook for a second
uh then we got uh
terrorist first of all Luffy is a
terrorist
I remember how like just out of left
field that line was yeah I mean yeah I
was just like that is the most Hassan
thing that he's ever said on this
podcast and you know what he's
completely there won't there ain't no
cap in that line man it was completely
right talking about you oh this is my
[__] face wait what this is my
favorite I don't remember this I really
hope this wins when I was making uranium
glass I really want to be careful
that's such a good sentence
so what I remember about this that stood
out to me uh because there was a lot of
this conversation that stood out to me
but one thing I remember vividly was uh
shouting on Nigel for being like you
don't know where you got the uranium
from the uranium because he was like
yeah remember where I got the uranium
from
he said I got it from an undisclosed
address yeah yeah yeah that's a that's
that he's been trained yeah yeah he
knows what to say yeah he does
uh I think this is Connor saying this he
said your your anus was creamy and I
don't know if I was prepared for that
I love this whole exchange it was just
asking to be moved you're right this is
creamy
I don't know
[Laughter]
so good screenshot of Joe he looks
horrible this is the one the shindo
element oh yeah this last one this is
when Joey's third eye opens this is me
like realizing the truth of the world
right here uh is shindo El saying what's
not vanilla about birth it was how is
birth not vanilla though
[Laughter]
you have to ask what what's happened to
make you think that like birth in
pornography is vanilla bro he's seen
some [__] no no he hasn't seen some [__]
he made this [__] yeah yeah yeah yeah I
mean like he is the guy who makes you
say you see the [__]
I think we've had an episode where I
think we've been so concerned with the
stuff that we said we're like maybe we
should cut this and get rid of this yeah
a lot that didn't make it into that
episode God my favorite part of that
clip is just Joey reaching Enlightenment
in that single line he's just like I
have found never I have found the
promised land I see everything now tags
dojin they're all the same I just didn't
realize you can ask that question and
not explode you know like I'm like oh my
god did you really just ask that I have
no idea what's going to win this one
honestly all these girls like all of
them I like all of them I I wish there
was a better like shorter clip for like
the null uh now of red conversation but
it's hard to there were so many little
moments of like what the [__] yeah well
all of his episodes I mean all of that
episode was just not Nigel says a line
and we're like what the [__] did you
just say yo yo go back go back it's
great because sometimes when you have
guests on and they say like they just
they explain in great detail about
everything they do but they don't
realize that this [__] is insane anyway
you can't do it and he's great because
he's just going off oh yeah you're like
this is insane what is this what am I
like what am I what are we listening to
here no what no no we did not all play
with fire and batteries as a kid we
don't procure not every kid did this we
did almost set a school on fire you know
we didn't mean like chlorine gas in our
free time growing up this is not normal
okay oh man I really want the Nigel one
to win but also I just love that shindo
clip as well another Uranus clip as well
yeah they're all good all right but
there can only be one winner I'm the
winner for the best out of context clip
is
Luffy is a terrorist
I wonder if there's a bit of recency
bias but also maybe maybe a reasonable
congratulations congratulations out of
context clip although honestly not that
much more context to it yeah it just
makes you think yeah
it's it's kind of like what what this
line reminds me of is remember like the
hits blunt meme from like [__] years
ago it's just like hits blunt Luffy is a
terrorist that's
that could apply to the wall
all right but what's the breakdown okay
one by a lot damn followed by God's
Chinese food
all right at least three took most of
the votes all right all right all right
you know what well there's a
congratulations
congrats all right the next one next one
is
oh my God now there are a lot of screen
Gap grabs Jabs gaps uh from either trash
taste episodes or stuff we got to off
camera and uh on our own personal [__]
as well uh so let's have a look at what
the nominations are this year
[Music]
I don't think this one is from this year
but I think it got more popular this
year yeah yeah I guess that kind of God
you look hideous in that yeah that was
Chris did me dirty in there uh that's
super super golf Bros what's happening
here oh that was I was teaching Conor
how to uh golf correctly you guys are
like Jordan and gold experience
uh POV you show your cousin domestic
girlfriend for the eighth time
yeah yeah that was from the uh jessups
episode uh anymore yeah we got some more
I believe
as me holding a Tango uh no explanation
there yeah Conor and pewdiepiece why did
Ludwig uh remove his like oh because he
had because he had like a tattoo on his
leg right yeah
okay but he but he didn't say he had a
tattoo on his leg and he just saw
stripping did you know it's bad I
obviously remember recording that
episode but I did not remember this
happening until I saw out of context
screenshots and I'm like did that happen
on the episode I feel like I felt like I
would remember that
uh and I I loved the bottom right one as
well yeah it's just such a good one it's
so perfectly your skin tone yeah it's
insane oh the body shoot the body's here
also the bottom left one
that is just that is just a trash taste
episode like in a nutshell you know it's
just like screen grabs yeah that's good
for me let's go back to the truck it's
got to be trucker the [__] with the
weak chin man the weekend is gonna be
the week
it has
well I guess we'll find out let's find
out he's the winner of the best screen
grab of the Year all right winner of the
best screen grab of the Year 2023 is
chocolate
leafy chin Corner let's go let's get all
the comments to f as well
that went by a lot yeah I want to know
how big this one boy
is shocking 39. 39
holy [__] [__] it no the biggest win the
biggest W so far half nearly half the
people voted for that yeah yeah second
place too much uh full cycle oh my God
what that's a massive discrepancy and
then third place
congratulations all good picks all great
picks yeah hell yeah I'm gonna use that
as my phone back I hope my chin never
ever recedes to that I'm hoping only
your hairline can receive because my
chin recedes oh [__] be a nose
breather you'll be all right yeah dude
that's not even yeah I can only breathe
yeah yeah
it's gone
oh my God yeah that's how Quentin
Tarantino looks when he sees feet yeah